[Música]
muito boa tarde a todos sejam bem-vindos
tentou que exerce
em primeiro lugar queria dizer que é um
orgulho muito grande para mim estar aqui
nesta escola a escola sobre a educação
onde eu tirei minhas emsetur e agradecer
efetivamente a italiana mafalda machismo
o convite ea honra estar aqui presente
principalmente é um prazer redobrado
porque neste na educação física tem nada
a ver com aquilo que foi apresentado até
agora mas neste ginásio e transpirar e
com certeza a forma como esta
hoje em dia temos tudo na forma das
nossas mãos
quando temos qualquer informação ou
ganhamos nosso marco no nosso tablet e
vasculhamos qualquer qualquer conteúdo
qualquer conteúdo dentro do nosso
equipamento móvel quem tem um smartphone
quem aqui na platéia também atenção quem
aqui na platéia
tem um tal amor sem câmera fotográfica
só para ter uma idéia na f8 que
aconteceu na califórnia nesta nesta
terça e na quarta feira mark zuckerberg
o frio que é a máquina fotográfica é a
primeira porta de entrada para o mundo
digital isso tivemos que comprar com ela
porque tiramos uma foto publicada
imediatamente nas redes sociais
publicamos indiretamente instagram no
facebook para termos como um amigo
através do voto certo em grupos de
amigos que nós temos cada vez mais é uma
porta de entrada para a informação a
vocês um equipamento móvel procura as
pesquisas de algum fornecedor algum
talento algum contato dentro renová não
conta facebook uma nova era digital
conteúdo digital o conteúdo é colocar
nossa palavra nós podemos criar conteúdo
esta nova era a promover a fazer a
desenvolver e tá nascer novas profissões
estão do cope copyright
são profissionais que estão cada vez
mais especializado no desenvolvimento de
conteúdos para redes sociais para blogs
e sites de aposta nesta área é uma área
que está em franca expansão e que podem
efetivamente e que eu acredito que é uma
grande mais valia não só nos conteúdos
normais ditos normais como os conteúdos
realidade aumentada
os conteúdos realidade aumentada que
parecem também ser alimentados pelo
público o público juntamente com outros
portais do consumidor para saber se há
valor ou não há valor daquela daquela
empresa que eu toda aquela daquela
companhia
contudo é importante também referir que
ter conteúdo não não por si só não é uma
mais valia que esse conteúdo seja o
vosso e que estejam devidamente
otimizados para o sistema mobile
hoje em dia as pesquisas imóvel e mobile
ea própria google nos dá essas
informações aumentou drasticamente
surpreendem muitas atividades em muitos
smartphones tablets e laptops desktops
desenvolver campanhas em desenvolver
estruturas martin é um erro um erro
identificada e está com resultados cada
vez mais as empresas querem trabalhar
este país feita no futuro vai vai criar
pra você vai criar valor para as
empresas que vocês forem florença
florença e forem efetivamente dar o
nosso contributo no processo evolutivo
no processo de valor
criem valor apresenta as funções que
combinem o mobile com conteúdos valente
com conteúdos voz agora não queria
deixar vos falar também efetivamente das
redes sociais
agora temos toda uma série de redes
sociais que temos que estar temos os
nossos clientes gostam e nós temos que
fazer companhia a ele o melhor serviço
possível
é muito importante que uma empresa e uma
empresa sem conseguir custa muito menos
do que custa é novo
ontem dois mil milhões em 2025 realidade
aumentada
toda a gente já pode consultar no
próprio facebook começa já tem tantos
que utilizam realidade aumentada dos
destaques do nosso rosto isto é
realidade aumentada
esta semana vamos trabalhar em ambientes
virtuais com realidade aumentada isto é
os nossos próprios em ambientes virtuais
utilizando
aumentava que é colocar nos dentes passo
por isso apostam nisto e são tecnologias
que estão a ser lançadas no mercado
a própria então fala se há rumores entre
blogs da sociedade vai apresentar no
próximo iphone
a própria tecnologia realidade aumentada
os óculos google plus usam tecnologia de
realidade aumentada os óculos rita
migração usam tecnologia de realidade
aumentada
só para vocês terem uma idéia dos
potenciais que isto tem e que isto pode
acrescentar tentava colocar objetos 3d
em três dimensões no ambiente real
existem quatro tipos realidade aumentada
vamos falar apenas de um que está ao
nosso alcance
há um que está ao nosso alcance são
desenvolvidos pelas próprias marcas por
grandes players como facebook google e
microsoft entre entre outros em portugal
também por isso vamos falar de um que
está o nosso até se pode ser usado para
para nós utilizarmos nas nossas
campanhas de marketing e para nós
efetivamente é acrescentar mais valor às
empresas que nós estamos a trabalhar
o primeiro a aparecer agora os browsers
da realidade aumentada mas alguns
pecados
existem diversas aumentada o chrome por
exemplo é um browser do usuário tem
diversas causas como o chrome mozilla a
própria realidade aumentada tem sua
cadeia os seus canais de distribuição
se vocês forem podem fazer a aplicação e
poder utilizar esta tecnologia por
exemplo existe uma aplicação que
conhecer viseu visão na palma das mãos
vocês podem saber através do vosso
equipamento apontando a câmera do vosso
equipamento está mais uma vez que o
marco do campeonato falou no dia 18 na
califórnia
a primeira porta de entrada para o mundo
digital dentro da realidade aumentada
terminada a dupla levado contaminado
espaço e não dizemos o vosso ponto de
geolocalização e
o que está a vossa volta e apontando a
arma para lá conseguem apenas com
simples cliques traçar o caminho para
esses preços quase espaço marcar ea
agendar reservar mesa e ter acesso
completamente o site completamente a
informação toda estava entre os jornais
online wikitude são o boa hair
são diversos browsers como crônico
internet só como mozilla e são
utilizados para poder potenciar
realidade aumentada
agora caso prático respostas rápidas a
informação que um exemplo fazemos um
google chrome
a um mês do arranque do google chrome
para poder potenciar para ler está
ativamente os quer pontos por isso quem
tem o seu smartphone devidamente
atualizado consegue através do google
chrome ler e esterco e tratar
efetivamente um trajeto já identificada
que ia ser viseu tem a utilização desta
diesel e consegue expressar a abrigos
diretamente no google mato um trajeto
para as 70 dizem quanto tempo
demoraremos que está no caminho
traçamos um trajeto isto é um trajeto
não há perdas onde uma onda é fidedigno
e conseguimos efetivamente ter não ter
erros na informação
imagine nós vamos visitar viseu 23 deu e
que temos um turista que vai ficar
alojado numa das unidades hoteleiras de
joão pessoa o turista chega a 94 na
próxima quarta em viseu vai conseguir
mobilizar essas coisas todas
olha direto para lá
faça aqui pra vocês esta agilidade ser
usadas para construir estas que vão
receber
temos que ver que nós vivíamos sabemos
que ser bem sabemos que o senhor vem
por isso vamos criar também algumas
ferramentas vamos renovar vamos criar
valor no sentido promover a nossa região
com alguma tecnologia com algum algum
clipe faz a diferença para a visita o
cliente chega o comentou o tempo o
visitante chega efetivamente a sé de
viseu quer por outro lado tem um outro
quer quanto que traça o caminho para
outra localidade que facilita a ligação
feita a comunicação entre entre entre as
empresas e entre o turismo em portugal
chegando chegando ao local tem um quer
com que ele abrirá automaticamente um
site ou uma aplicação que diz onde que a
porta de entrada onde pode gerar os
boletos
como é para o percurso adentrou o que
não deve ver o que não deve ver uma
coisa fantástica traduz para a língua
materna da pessoa
isto é já viram a facilidade que vocês
irem para a china o irã apenas não quer
como não percebem nada daqui umas
traduzidos para português e você sabe
identificar em perceber quando é que
vocês estão o que tem a volta imagina
maktub importância que isso tem para o
turismo kroll por exemplo uma campanha
da vitória simples
nós temos poder sair da caixa fazer
coisas acusadas inteligentes coisas e
inteligente
isso foi a campanha mais vista de que é
contra determinado aumentava no mundo
porque não sei por que alguém vai ter
que explicar por que mas que acham
engraçado acho que isso aqui coloquei
aqui pra você ver são exemplos que podem
efetivamente acrescentar valor às
empresas
agora uma coisa muito simples uma coisa
muito simples o tempo também já está a
terminar uma coisa muito simples vocês
toda toda a gente hoje em dia tem
inúmeros cartões muitas muitas pessoas
recebem cartões atrás cartões cartões
atrás de cartões o que acontece muitas
vezes estes cartões o lixo ou temos que
estar no nosso martony e introduzir
manualmente manualmente os dados todos
da pessoa certa vez enganados
só queremos introduzir um novo
introduzimos 16 14 15 por clicamos 1
sentirá e quando queremos falar com essa
pessoa vai parar
o mix está do outro lado do mundo com
este percurso com esta tecnologia irá
aumentar vá nos cartões vocês conseguem
ter toda a informação automaticamente
dentro automaticamente dentro da vasta
lista de contactos
quem ler o cartão quem é que quer contém
noma emel site telemóvel murmurava toda
a informação área da ti visada áreas
preferência linhas de apoio tem toda a
informação e uma informação sem acesso a
todos os conteúdos de um cliente para
não andarmos com uma carteira cheia
cartões ontem que os chamados cartões
casos não estão limitados a um canto
onde ascendendo agora numa noite fria de
inverno é que não conseguiu ser efetivo
em toda a informação no nosso mar phone
uma forma rápida intuitiva e super super
super super haja muito obrigado